foreign
Salt Lake City Utah what's up Bailey
hey how are you just I'm dancing on the
ceiling Lionel Richie style what are you
doing
I Lost Boy so what's up
so um in the past year I have gone
through a season of some pretty
heightened anxiety and a lot of feelings
like that that I hadn't ever really
experienced before and now I feel like
I'm kind of coming out on the other side
of that and coming through some of those
things and now I feel like I have
anxiety about having anxiety like
scared congratulations you're official
uh what what uh what was the impetus
behind the increased anxiety what
happened last year
um well I was in my first year of law
school Bailey lead with that I started
law school you can just put a period
into that it's like oh you're gonna be
anxious and depressed and why like good
grief how was it
um it was good and I really enjoyed my
it was a great year I really like
enjoyed my experience and I'm glad that
I am through it for sure
um but I think it definitely like
sparked just this heightened level of
all those types of feelings that I had
to deal with that I had never dealt with
before and now I'm like
scared when I start to feel like that a
little bit I feel like I'm scared to
kind of go back to that place that I was
in oh excellent okay
so do you know my background with law
with lawyers and law students
um just a little bit okay I was a dean
of students at a law school okay and
it's been five years it was
transformative for me
um
as a non-jd person someone with who's
not there's not a uh an attorney
I don't know that there's anybody else
in the country that's got more respect
for law students law faculty members and
the attorney I just think
um I love everything about it and I also
spent five years plus an additional
three years studying lawyer mental
health and whoa right
yeah you're like yes yes so
um I'm gonna rattle things off the top
of my head here okay
um
I'm gonna make a note real quick because
uh part okay
so here's what I noticed in my students
and here's what the literature said is
I'm just gonna braid it all together
okay
number one the pressure of law school is
no joke
the top 15 of you will make this much
more money than the rest of the others
the top 30 of you will get these jobs
and the rest of you will be left to be
involved in a type of Hunger Games for
the rest of the jobs this group will
make two hundred thousand the rest of
you will make forty eight thousand plus
commission right it's no joke and it's
not like a
you know I'm kind of thinking they're
very clear about it right yeah
yeah and then
you've been the smartest person in your
area in your Sphere for a long time or
at least one of the smartest that you
know and then they dump you into law
school into first year 1l class
and you look around you're like oh
everybody's a laser
yeah and even that dude over there who's
wearing like the Pantera shirts and he's
got a mohawk turns out he missed zero
questions on the act right yeah I mean
like you know what I mean and yeah he's
smoking weed in the parking lot yet he's
way smart like the whole it it blows up
every Paradigm you have right
yeah and that's unnerving and so the
identity you built on being the smart
person the safety you felt being the
smart one is now it's gone and a lot of
people experience this when they
graduate college and they go to their
first job like oh yeah I'm a hard worker
and then you show up and you're like
everybody here is a hard worker and if
you make that sale
you take food off my plate so you don't
make that sale that's my set right now
all of a sudden you're like I don't do
it and then your body just starts
sounding the alarms Okay the third one
is you stay up you work 20 hours a day
is that fair
yeah yes it's studying studying studying
studying and then the whole uh what I
don't tell me about law school you are
attending but
um is it so crowd is Socratic I mean do
they you they say read the chapter okay
awesome okay so if you don't know what
that is you're just listening to this
here's how law school Works they say
read 500 pages between now and next
class and that doesn't mean just scan
your eyeballs over it that means you are
going to chart out everything you read
all of the cases why the attorneys did
what they did why the judge said what
the judge said why the plaintiffs and
the defendants did what they did you're
going to go through all of that and then
you show up to class
and your professors at the front of the
class and he may say Bailey
tell us about case whatever and Bailey
stands up and for the next 45 minutes
it's Bailey versus the professor
why do you think that what happened
right that is and in most law classes
it's completely random right
yes yeah so you don't know if you're
gonna get shot you just go to class and
you're like I'm just going to class
going to class you on display hour go
and you're in front of all your
classmates who you want to be impressed
you want to impress you want to have
um you want to line up you know you want
to be the first I want to be this I want
to be included on their journals what
that is a recipe for anxiety if you're
not anxious when that you're possibly
sociopathic
people that every day they're like I
hope to God that faculty member calls on
me because I'm going to burn them to the
ground and they get called on and they
stand up and you can tell they like it
right yeah yeah there are those people
you're you're not that person most
people are not that person right those
people go on to become uh law professors
they're incredible right they love every
second of this
um and then here's the other extreme
their research tells me that
when you make partner whatever that
looks like and I'm just assuming you're
going to go to a firm okay instead of
going into public service if you make a
partner
the research tells me that you walk out
and you get a massive
bonus a massive increase in your check
you also get a massive increase in the
responsibility of the firm and the
plaintiffs and the people's lives you're
impacting and
there's this
um
terrifying feeling
that I gave up my 20s
I gave up most of my 30s
I gave up Little League games I gave up
Saturdays I gave up hikes I gave up
fishing
and it wasn't worth it
does that make sense
yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense law
school has an incredible way
of making you a different type of
thinker that's its job and I'm so
grateful for it
and it has a very unique way of pulling
you apart from your why why am I doing
this
why am I trying to get on this journal
why do I want to be in the top 25 of my
class why do I want to work at this
particular firm and they continue to
push you towards external metrics look
at the cars you can have at the homes
you can have at the money you can have
and if that's what you're about that's
what you're about man there's people who
do it for years and years and years and
years and years I've just set at a lot
of the lawyers assistance programs
meeting I've I've met with them I've
researched them I've presented at their
conferences
true man
it's an exhausted burned out tired crew
right
yeah and I think that I you know there's
a plan that they like put you on in law
school that you're gonna graduate and
you're gonna go to a big firm and you're
going to make a lot of money and I am
kind of
not bought into that plan and I am like
in this season of being like I want to
build a good life for myself not just a
good job for myself and so trying to
balance that all at one time is
challenging to say the least and so then
and I'm also just at Heart Like a
planner like I would have every detail
of everything planned out for the rest
of my life if I had the capability and
so I kind of feel like a lot of days I'm
just in a constant like mental battle
with myself of like I want to do this or
no I want to do this or this is what I
want to do or but I can't control this
aspect but I want to control this aspect
and
I feel like I am coming through some of
those things and learning how to handle
some of those things but then when I
start to feel like that again I almost
like Panic like I'm like oh God like I
don't want to go I don't want to go back
to what I was doing before all right so
the the devil of anxiety is that once it
it passes
that it creates new anxiety about being
anxious right you said it perfectly the
last time okay so I want you to think of
your first year of law school have you
ever been water skiing
I have not okay actually when you're in
the water and the boat goes it hit they
Hammer the boat and they start pulling
you out of the water the first hundred
yards or so you are half of your body is
underwater and half of you is above
water and you're just it's like somebody
spraying you in the face with a fire
hose yeah and then when you Crest and
get on top of the water it turns into
glass
so you just have to get through that
initial what is happening
and that's where a lot of people fall
off if you look at the number of people
who just have hookups the number the
people who start drinking too much
people who put on a lot of weight who
quit exercising it's that first year
it's trying to deal with that Onslaught
coming
so on the other side of this you're on
the other side of it now you're just
waiting to be submerged and sprayed in
the face again at will come it will come
make no mistake
walking around clinched up waiting for
it a won't make it hurt any less when it
gets you and B is just gonna ruin the
days that you're not getting sprayed in
the face
yeah that makes sense so here's the
simple word awareness
when you start to tense up thinking
about being anxious in The Future Smile
take a huge deep breath and hold it for
three to five seconds relax breathe it
out and consciously pull your shoulders
down as far as they will go
and say okay
it's gonna come some point not today
then the next day not today and what
you'll do over time is you will teach
your amygdala you will teach your brain
that you are driving
and it will know okay this is harrowing
this is scary this is stressful but
she's in control we don't have to go to
fight or flight
that makes sense yeah we're only going
to take care of our brain and listen
I'm always like okay sure when a 1l
tells me I'm gonna do this and then this
and when I'm 33 I'm gonna do this I
always do like oh man I'm gonna hand you
my card and win this supernovas which it
will
um give me a call right your obsession
with planning is a is an anxiety
response
it's fake control it's pretend
and you think you've wrapped the world
up in your fancy planner and your apps
you haven't it just is a way to to
neutralize the anxiety
and so we're going to make a plan for
today we're going to make a plan for
this semester and we're going to hold it
Loosely we're gonna we're gonna follow
that plan to a t until that plan turns
left and we're gonna go left
and then we're gonna make a new plan and
that it's gonna be annoying it's gonna
be frustrating but it's not going to be
anxiety inducing because we know it's
coming
is that fair
yeah that's what we're going to practice
okay I'm gonna give you two other things
that I want you to do as a law student
okay okay make friends
regularly see them even at the expense
of studying sometimes and especially
people that are not law students
themselves
okay okay law students and lawyers
their weapon of choice is human
interaction
and when you're a boxer or an MMA
fighter you go to work you go to the gym
to practice fighting and you put on
gloves and you put in a mouthpiece and
you punch other people and then you take
your gloves off and your mouthpiece off
and you go to the grocery store and you
can't punch people at the grocery store
because you're not at work anymore
attorneys do not have
um
they don't take their gloves off they
don't take their mouth pieces out they
just go to the grocery store
and you know you are learning skills
because this is your job to defend the
the people who have no voice
you know how to eviscerate somebody how
to take somebody apart and because
that's have you already been accused at
the at the kitchen table of or
Thanksgiving dinner they're like ah
right all right that's enough yeah my
mom tells me I'm worrying her yeah you
know why because you are you're like a
kid that just got a Nerf gun and you're
shooting everybody with it it's fun but
only for you and here's what happens
your circle gets smaller and smaller
because people don't want to hang out
with you as much anymore because all you
talk about is this and this and can you
believe this and have you read the whole
thing on your Apple iPhone the whole ins
like section you know what they're they
actually take you're that person and
then you only end up hanging out with
other attorneys and everyone's exhausted
and everyone's trying to one-up the
other one and so then you start meeting
at bars and then now we're down the road
see what I'm saying
that group of friends I have a good
group of friends at school but that
breeds just a lot of the anxiety and
stuff too like it's great to talk talk
to other people about the experience but
I also like fully believe that law
school is a very individual experience
for every person and so sometimes
hearing about everybody else's just just
like oh God yeah and if you're like well
I didn't think that class was that hard
then they look at you like oh you're one
of them and if you say oh that class was
so hard they're like I've got her nailed
to the wall right there's yeah it's you
have to have community in law school
period attorneys have to have community
at their firm in the local bar
associations you got to do that and also
you've got to have friends that are not
in that world that are just talking
about their pets and Lawn Care and
things like that you've got to have
other people and finally
I recommend to every single attorney uh
law school a law student every single
attorney in training
start talking to somebody now whether
it's a coach whether it's a counselor
somebody who is going to consciously and
with some regularity challenge you
are you still connected to why you're
doing this in the first place
where are you on your why where are you
on your purpose why are you going
through all of this hell that is law
school
because if it's for 125 000 a year it's
not worth it
if it's to become
credentialed so that you can help
anybody and you can take on the big guy
you can help the little guy you can make
the world a better place then law school
three years is nothing
because you'd walk through fire to help
people in your community
and that's why I just think I've I'm I
have such high respect for law students
and law firmers and attorneys because of
what they are able to do for the least
of these in our communities and yes
there's morons there's morons in every
industry good grief should you should be
a part of the podcasting industry
there's morons in my house I'm one of
them so like there's morons everywhere
but I'm just so impressed I I don't I
got a couple of doc phds I don't think I
could have done law school I I couldn't
have gone to war like that every day and
so I'm so in awe of you who do it
um
like Bailey
I want you to always remember who you're
gonna be at the other end of law school
as you enter the legal profession as you
fight for a living for other people
where can you take those gloves off take
your mouthpiece off and say whoo I'm
Bailey
let's go get something to eat talk about
dogs or pets or whatever it is